>>Sparky: And welcome once again to the weekly
Android developer office hours.
This is your EMEA edition coming to you in
the middle of the afternoon again.
Lovely sunny or almost sunny London UK.
Where I am visiting from Munich and I'm joined
by my local cohorts.
Rich, Nick, and Matt.
And also joined by Roman from New York, New
York.
We are here to take on any and all questions
related to Android development.
So let's see what's going on.
>>Rich: Well, as usual we won't be making
any announcements on Roadmaps, future product
releases and things like that.
So please don't ask 'cause we'll just say
"No."
If you want to join the hangout live, come
in and ask questions, then please just comment
on the thread on the plus Android developers
Google plus page.
And I'll add you in and you can come with
us live.
If not, as the questions on the Moderator
or on the thread.
We will answer them live on here.
So, we might as well get started.
We do actually have one person live in the
hangout already.
Yosi
>>Yosi: Oh.
Hi.
>>Rich: Did you actually have a question,
Yosi?
>>Yosi: Yeah, two questions.
First of all, about the play services API,
and, all the jar and when it should come out
and we can use it, live.
If you can have an answer for that.
And secondly about fragments.
It can wait until you answer the first one.
>>Rich: Well the answer to the play services
API.
Question's pretty quick.
'cause that's a future roadmap question.
We don't have an answer for you right now.
We can't comment on that.
So if you just move on to the fragments, we'll
hopefully help you with that one.
>>Yosi: OK, I'm trying to do a fragment, dialup
fragment.
That should be in a popup above or two pane
fragments.
And I want the view to stop, to wait and to,
so the user can select the account he needed.
You know I wanted to do something like that.
Select the Google account.
But if I'll do the down fragment it continues
to the next fragment and won't wait.
Is there any option to hold the UI until the
user waits for the selection?
What's the best option to do it?
>>Roman: Can you rephrase the part of the
question where you're saying it goes on so
that it—
>>Yosi: Actually I'm trying to use Account
Manager to get all the Google accounts.
And show popup screens for the user to choose
which Google account I can use to do auth
with the API.
And [pause] oh, OK.
>>Rich: Sorry about that.
We just dropped out for a second there.
[laughter]
>>Yosi: Should I repeat the question again?
>>Rich: yeah if you don't mind.
>>Yosi: Yeah, OK.
From the start.
I'm using account manager to do auth for my
application to get all the contacts from the
Google besides the synced ones.
So the user won't get a popup in the download
fragment saying which Google account he wants
to use.
Or maybe add a new one.
And then the next fragment should be where
I'm scraping out the entire address book or
contacts.
But the problem is, when I'm popping out the
first fragment, I'm getting some intensely
moving forward to the next fragment.
And I want to know what should I do.
[video cuts out]
>>Roman: the UI thread, right?
I mean the dialog fragment also like the interaction
with the dialog fragment also happens on the
UI thread.
And you know, before fragments, what you could
do is probably have it as a separate activity
that would have a dialog scene.
>>Yosi: Yeah.
>>Roman: But the activity underneath it would
be in the "start it but pause" state.
So, just, and I don't wanna answer the question
straight on here.
But I think it may depend on a couple of things.
But what I would do, instead of using a dialog
all together, have a kind of a first step.
So it would be a full screen activity or a
full screen fragment in that activity that
will let you select that account.
Once you select that account, it either goes
on to the next activity or just pops the account
selection fragment from the core layout.
And shows the next fragment.
So basically, my short answer, so this will
be, don't use a dialog fragment.
Just use an inline account selection fragment.
Any of you guys have any other thoughts?
>>Nick: Works for me
[laughter]
>>Rich: Yes.
>>Yosi: [laughs] OK.
>>Roman: Is there a reason you aren't doing
that?
Or is there just the basic—
>>Yosi: No, uh, what I'm trying to do is make
a more generic approach.
Because I want to make the user options to
be like, I can choose the Google account.
I can choose the Twitter account, I can choose
a Facebook account.
And so on and so on.
And I'm going to Account Manager getting all
the accounts by types.
And each time I'm popping out a selector for
all the appropriate accounts, and the user
can also add the new account according to
the type he chose.
But then, when I'm popping up the dialog,
sometimes it just doesn't wait 'til the user
selects.
And just goes, moves on to the next selector,
fragment.
What I did, was divided the dialog to two
options.
And then popped up the window with the dialog
fragment.
And just waited until the return from the
o-auth.
And then I moved on.
But, it's not so good 'cause sometimes you
need, you see the UI thread hangs for a bit.
And that's why I wanted to know if you, if
there was any other options to do it.
>>Roman: Yeah, and I mean, just in case, I
don't know if I follow this entirely.
But just in case you're kind of assuming that
there's blocking involved when you pop up
the fragment.
That's gonna block the function that triggered
the dialog fragment that called the show method.
That doesn't actually block.
So what I would do instead, assuming you have
to use the dialog fragment, and like I said
earlier you probably shouldn't use a dialog
in this case.
But assuming you have to, you shouldn't have,
or sort of assume any blocking operations.
Just use a series of callbacks.
So don't actually add the next fragment until
you get the callback that, the user—
>>Yosi: Yeah, and that's what I did eventually.
But I wanted to know if there is a better
option than that.
>>Roman: No, there's—
>>Yosi: So the callback, sometimes when you
get the call back in, you see the dialog still
hangs about half a second until you get to
the new fragment and so on.
And so I wanted to be a bit more precise on
the UI and not be so much delayed.
>>Roman: Yeah, I mean if it's hanging, it
might be like you, you are blocking the UI
sort of with something.
Off the top of my head, I can't think of.
>>Nick: Yeah, I'd probably instrument that
and try to find out what's going on during
that sort of user assist phase.
Assist rates.
Find out what's going on during that time.
>>Yosi: OK.
>>Roman: yeah, if it's in dialog fragment,
you may wanna file a bug.
If you know, you're not doing anything yourself
on the UI thread and the dialog is hanging
on the screen for half a second, it sounds
like it might be bug for the dialog.
>>Nick: You wanna make sure you move all the
logic.
Like on the click handle on the dialog.
So the first thing it does is hide it.
And any business logic that happens after
the click, happens like in the callback.
So that you know, there's nothing stopping
the—
>>Yosi: Yeah, yeah.
I'm doing a [assig] task on the callback.
So the callback returns to the holder activity.
And then triggers an event about half a second.
That's why I'm trying to see if that's the
real issue here.
OK.
That's nice.
>>Rich: Alright.
Thanks.
>>Yosi: Thank you.
>>Rich: Cheers.
Thanks for coming in today.
>>Yosi: Bye-bye.
>>Rich: Alright then, during that conversation
we've also been joined by Alex Lucas.
Some other guy.
[laughter]
>> Zach Galfin, I guess.
>> Right.
>>Rich: Any one of those names, he would answer
to.
So feel free to ask questions to him as well.
When will that meet?
What are your special subjects, Alex?
>>Alex: I like Android.
[laughter]
>>Rich: [inaudible]
>>Alex: Before Android, I was on the analytics
team.
So I've covered a lot of stuff on implementing
analytics in Android.
Also accessibility and just general frameworking
questions.
>>Rick: So if you wanna ask questions about
Android, Android, Android, Android, Android
or Google TV
[laughter]
Please jump in.
Hey, Chrome pusher.
Nice.
Um, yeah.
Feel free to jump in.
we'll have a look quick on the thread.
I wonder if people are on holiday.
We usually have quite a lot of question on
the thread by now.
>>Sparky: It's a holiday today.
>>Rich: In Germany?
>>Sparky: Yes.
In Bavaria.
>>Rich: In Bavaria they have a public holiday.
>>Sparky: Yes, yes.
Today is Assumption day.
Also known for assumptions
>>Rich: for assumptions?
>>Sparky: Also known as Bavarian Himmelfahrt.
>>Rich: Ding.
[laughter]
OK, in which case let's have a look through
some of the Moderator questions.
>>Nick: Yes.
>>Rich: The first Moderator question is asking
about something, a future product.
Release slash announcement.
>>Roman: When will we be able to add our own
location providers?
>>Rich: We can't.
>>Roman: Well, I think, I believe, and I haven't
verified this myself.
I haven't created a sample up to do it.
But I believe that if you check the "allow
mock locations" check box, somewhere in your
system, you can actually install third party
providers.
Having said that, I don't know what the APIs
are to do so.
>>Rich: Where is that?
On Developers?
[inaudible]
>>Roman: Somewhere in Developers.
>>Rich: Somewhere in applications development.
>>Roman: Yeah.
I mean the reason being like, you don't want
just any app to willy nilly add like a fake
GPS provider.
Right?
Because then you know, any apps that rely
on GPS or whatever for example, GeoFencing
or you know, making sure the content is restricted
by geography.
If somebody is using that, then you'd basically
get fake results.
So I believe that 's why it's hidden behind,
or disabled by default.
And enableable for development purposes.
Having said that, I honestly don't know how
to create a provider.
I know the emulator kind of has "fake provider"
because it needs to let you specify GPS coordinates
manually.
But yeah, there's gotta be an API somewhere.
If not then, don't know.
>>Sparky: Well you were definitely right on
about the developer options.
'cause there it is.
Developer options.
>>Roman: We should probably double check if
there is an API.
I mean, you can probably extend the location
provider.
Having said that, I don't know how you would
register that.
I don't know if an API for that exists.
>>Sparky: Maybe I should dust off my old Bluetooth
GPS book.
[laughter]
>>Rich: Excellent.
OK, the next question on the Moderator is
"How can I create an add-on dictionary.
Bilingual.
I find that anything I type in other languages
is automatically edited.
This is very frustrating.
Find the options in language input and your
keyboard add-on dictionaries."
Anybody know about add-on dictionaries.
>>Sparky: He's talking about add-on.
I turned on a couple alternative languages
just for typing input.
But, only the ones that came stock with the
system.
>>Rich: Mm-hm.
We're going to where he says—
>>Roman: Personal dictionaries?
>>Matt: Even and added one would you be able
to still type in a different language, keyboard,
and work out which one you're going for?
>>Sparky: You tell it which one you want to
switch too.
So there's a little globe icon.
Yeah.
>>Matt: Message bar.
[pause]
>>Roman: Oh, add-on dictionaries, there it
is.
>>Rich: Right on page [unintelligible] under
"Text correction."
>>Roman: Oh, this is, yeah, this may be a
new API.
Yeah.
Either Ice Cream Sandwich or Jellybean.
>>Rich: Oh here.
>>Roman: This may be new.
So I mean, one way you could do it is assuming
this is new, 'cause for example, the emoji,
that was never there before.
Anyway.
>>Sparky: Yeah, that's definitely Jellybean.
>>Roman: So if it's new we could probably
just take a look at the API disc.
Between Jellybean and Ice Cream Sandwich.
Just to see.
I don't know if we should do it now?
If you guys want?
If you have time?
You probably have time.
>>Rich: Well, let's all, let's take a look
at it in the background while we go on to
the next question.
>>Roman: Yeah, let's go on.
I'll take a look and--
>>Rich: And then we can come back and continue.
[pause]
Are you keeping check on the air?
>>Alex: Researching live on the air.
[chuckles]
[laughter]
>>Rich: We're just that kind of crowd.
OK.
"Have you considered" This is from Ken Dawood
in Teesside.
"Have you considered making developers.Android.com
a community editable like wiki?"
I certainly haven't.
Do you?
>>Sparky: I've thought about it.
>>Rich: You've thought about it?
What'd you think?
[chuckles]
>>Sparky: It's hard.
I mean, besides which, we already have something
like that.
There's like stackoverflow and many other
sites like it.
We have our forums as well.
So.
>>Rich: We do have a very hardworking, dedicated
team of tech writers.
[pause]
>>Sparky: Oh wow, check this out.
>>Rich: Sorry about.
Just dropped out the Hangout just briefly
there for a second.
>>Sparky: How are things?
>>Matt: I don't know.
I think that actually it's, when you actually
have something that has a definitive right
and wrong, and you have somebody who is making
it definitively right or wrong, it kind of
makes a lot of sense for them to be the ones
to document that.
>>Rich: Yeah.
I can understand why you want it as well.
Because there are things in the documentation
that get out of date.
And people file bugs and we update them and
things.
But it would be good to have more manpower
behind it.
As Matt says, yeah, it is nice to have the
definitive guide there.
And we do have other sources.
On the Google groups.
Stackoverflow.
Etcetera.
>>Roman: It mentioned something about the
add-on dictionary.
[video cuts out]
>>Roman: Provider of user-defined words for
input methods to use for predictive text input.
Applications and info methods may add words
into the dictionary.
So this seems like this will just add something
to your existing dictionary.
So you can create an app that's basically,
just, if you have 20 words you wanna add,
yeah, you just kind of looking at an add-on
dictionary manager.
Maybe even imports things from the cloud or
what not.
>>Alex: You should probably write a sample
app-er in a U class for that.
>>Roman: Mm. that sounds good.
Pretty good idea.
>>Sparky: We already have a dictionary sample.
>>Alex: Hm?
>>Sparky: we already have a dictionary sample.
We could extend it.
>>Roman: But there's probably something that's
specific to Jellybean.
And I haven't found it yet.
Oh well.
Wait, Android.
Yeah.
That's probably all we could say at this time
about it.
>>Sparky: OK.
>>Rich: OK.
Oh.
[pause]
Anyone wanna take a look at that one there?
>>Sparky: How is [goodee] at google.com bug
tracker for Android handled?
Oh, it's is that the one we were looking [on]
or the end one?
>>Roman: Yeah, this one.
Yeah.
>>Sparky: Right.
There are tons of very very old issues that
are now,
>>Alex: [Inaudible]
>>Sparky: that are not now even assigned.
Others are fixed but the ticket is still open.
Yes, well curating multiple, I mean, curating
the bug trackers that we have internal to
the company is hard enough.
Let alone curating ones that are external
facing as well, what with two or three or
five or 700,000 users all wanting to contribute
their own bugs.
>>Alex: The best way, if there's a bug on
the public bug tracker and you want us to
get a better look at it, is to link to it
and make sure that it gets uploaded in startalot.
So that it will sort of float to the top of
the sidebars.
We don't necessarily go by the age of the
bug so much as the importance of the bug.
And the number of starts that the bug receives
is the main metric for that.
>>Sparky: Yeah, look for a question that already
touches on what you want, and upload that.
>>Alex: Right.
>>Sparky: Rather than forking a new one.
I will say, also, that they, I believe that
that list actually does influence our development
course in some cases.
I suspect that a large part of the reason
why we made such leaps and bounds of improvement
in bidirectional text input for Ice Cream
Sandwich and Jellybean was because of those
bugs that had sat up at the top of the queue
of collected thousands and thousands of forks.
>>Alex: Right.
And it was not thousands and thousands of
bugs saying the same thing.
It was a couple of bugs with thousands and
thousands of bugs.
>>Rich: Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
So reconciling bugs we fix into maybe ones
that have been raised externally is also tricky.
People try and do it.
But obviously the Android team are fixing
quite a lot of bugs for each release and they
can't go through the entire bug tracker seeing
if someone's raised that externally and then
closing it off.
So there are definitely bugs in the tracker
that are fixed one ticket [unintelligible]
[pause]
OK.
Ask, oh, someone's asking whether they can
ask a question.
Uh.
Yeah, you can.
[laughter]
Yeah.
>>Rich: We'd love you to ask the question
on media APIs live and we'll see what we can
do.
>>Alex: Well, we're not really here to "answer
questions."
[laughter]
>>Rich: We are, I, I don't know—
>>Roman: We need a really dodge questions.
That's—
>>Alex: Mostly.
>>Rich: We've got a new question just popped
in.
"Hi, I need to create an app which will play
videos from YouTube and show external subtitles
for the played video.
Can you please advise me on how to start or
if it's even possible?"
>>Roman: Well.
>>Nick: Yeah, there's a talk in Google IO
which is about doing just this.
There's a new player library which allows
you to embed YouTube videos.
And I think do subtitles as well, right?
>>Roman: The YouTube library.
So that was announced, but it's not yet available.
>>Nick: Yeah.
It's not yet available.
So keep an eye on developers.google.com.
>>Alex: Is there a workaround for right now?
>>Roman: YouTube videos and captioning?
>>Yosi: Using the web view.
>>Nick: It's embedded web view for most people.
>>Roman: Yeah.
>>Nick: But it's not—
>>Roman: Uh, that'll work, actually that'll
probably rely on flash, or is it going to
use HTML5.
>>Yosi: HTML5.
>>Roman: HTML5?
HTML5 in web view is Android 3.0 or higher.
>>Nick: And it's not great.
It's been actually, I'd say it wouldn't be
worth at this point going down the path of
writing that.
Because there's later APIs coming out.
>>Roman: Yeah, just hold tight.
In terms of captions though, I'm not sure
if it supports, I mean it supports—
>>Nick: We had it in IO, I don't know whether
that was--
>>Sparky: There's a difference between turning
on captions in the viewport and like, getting
a feed of the captions like in display next
to it in your UI.
>>Roman: Yeah.
Let's just table that question until that
library is released.
It was announced [inaudible] development.
>>Rich: Hey there.
See, we moved back to the Moderator.
We've got Oiwani joined us, if that's how
you pronounce your name, hopefully.
>>Oiwani: Yeah.
>>Rich: Hi there.
Have you got a question for us today, or have
you just come in to say hello?
>>Oiwani: Hi.
>>Sparky: Yes, yes, we hear you.
So, are you doing Android development at the
moment?
Is there something—?
>>Oiwani: Yeah, yeah.
I'm doing Android development.
Yeah in Nigeria.
>>Roman: Awesome.
>>Oiwani: I'm developing on the Google page
a reality application using the Android platform.
Using the camera location services.
>>Rich: Awesome:
>>Roman: Great.
Do you have any questions.
Like technical questions or best practice
or something like that?
>>Oiwani: No, no, no, not at the moment.
I just came to learn.
To see what's up.
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Roman: OK.
>>Rich: Well thanks for dropping in, just
stay there, and maybe if you do have questions,
just shout them out.
Moderator is now complete I think.
>>Roman: There should be one more somewhere
in there.
Probably.
Yeah.
>>Rich: Oh yeah.
"Could you recommend a sample project to do
low level media API?"
Uh, the best thing at the moment would be
the YouTube videos again.
The YouTube video from Google IO this year
on the low-level APIs has loads of samples
in it and sample code and how to do it.
Also the top of the classes for media codec,
in the API doc.
There's a bunch of sample code in there as
well.
I'll try and post the link to that quickly.
>>Roman: [humming]
>>Yosi: I have another question if you can
answer.
>>Rich: Alright, go for it.
>>Roman: Let's hear it.
>>Yosi: OK, making a widget.
Home screen widget.
>>Rich: Mm-hmm.
>>Yosi: And the main issue is when sometimes
you do a pending intent if you want to do
an on click on the view, so you go back to
the activity.
But sometimes it happens that you click on
the widget.
You go back to the application.
And you go back and forth for some, like,
four or five clicks.
And then when you click again on the widget,
on the home screen, you get an exception.
That you cannot send pending intent.
>>Rich: Hm.
>>Nick: Did it tell you why?
Does it give any more of its stat regs?
>>Yosi: That's the only, if you want I can
try and see just a second.
It gave me—
>>Rich: Is this happening during development
or with the production version of the app.
>>Yosi: Same thing.
It doesn't influence if it's on production
or not.
But the main issue is, here, it's I'm trying
to make a distinct unique intent each time
I click on the button so it won't happen again.
After the, when I go back and forth from the
context.
But just a second.
I'm looking for the stat. [pause]
>>Roman: So are you creating a new task every
time?
>>Yosi: No, I'm not creating a new task.
I'm creating a new intent.
A new pending intent.
>>Roman: Right, but is that creating a new--
so for example, let's say you touch the widget
and you—
>>Yosi: Yeah, you must use the flag, "create
new tabs" each time you use a pending intent.
Or is there another option?
>>Rich: No, that's-- is that necessarily true?
>>Nick: [unintelligible]
>>Rich: Do you have to create a new task every
time you create new tabs?
>>Roman: It doesn't seem like that's a mandatory
flag.
>>Rich: No.
I think, having intents, that's the concept
of them.
I mean you can pass them around and other
people can watch.
>>Roman: Yeah.
Um, I mean, just, as an example, like in our
design guidelines we have this updated section
of navigation.
And it talks about-- and this is not Android
developers.
This is around the interaction and the design
guidelines.
There's a section that covers how to navigate
into your app deeply into your app from a
widget or a notation.
And the implication there is that when you
jump into your app from a widget, you shouldn't
be creating a new task every time.
You shouldn't, in your recent, when you touch
on recents, you shouldn't see four or five
different instances of your app.
>>Yosi: No, you won't see.
You'll see only one.
You'll see only one instance on recents.
>>Roman: OK.
>>Yosi: But each time you create a pending
intent, because you're not going from a context
of a specific activity, you must declare the
flag new task or clear task and so on.
And after a few back and forth clicks from
going to inside the app, going back to home,
you know, exiting the app.
You know, finish all the Google, all the application
resources, and then going back to the widget
and clicking again, after a few times it just
gives me the exception.
I'm trying to find the stack.
I saved it on a text file.
And just wanted to see--
>>Rich: [unintelligible]
>>Yosi: OK.
Give me a few minutes and when time—
>>Roman: We can get back to that.
>>Rich: Hey, Atar.
Good to see you made it along this week.
Atar?
Frozen.
Can you hear me?
>>Atar: Hey.
Hey.
Hello.
>>Rich: You have a question on the Moderator?
>>Atar: [unintelligible]
>>Rich: You have a new question.
[unintelligible, feedback echoing]
Atar, we've got some feedback coming through
on your speakers.
>>Atar: Oh, I was thinking we'd just lower
that.
It [inaudible]
>>Rich: [inaudible] Yeah.
[inaudible]
[pause]
Um, was it, uh, should read that.
>>Roman: "Was it intentional that shortcuts
aren't part of the new Jellybean widget design
guidelines?
Since they live in the widget drawer in four
point oh plus, are you phasing them out, discouraging
their use?"
No.
It was intentional that they were left out?
They're not widgets.
They're short cuts.
In terms of what the user sees, we happened
to place them in the same area.
Because to a user they may not make a difference.
But in terms of your design.
I mean, shortcut design is, we probably should
have another guideline for like, what should
be in the app drawer.
Which go on the home screen.
But it doesn't really belong in the widget
design guidelines.
It'll probably be a separate guideline.
So we don't treat them the same.
Although users may kind of understand them.
They may have the same mental model for them.
But yeah.
So, it's not intentional that they're not
in the design guidelines altogether.
But that's just a matter of priorities whether
or not we'll be able to add things like shortcuts.
So.
>>Nick: So I wouldn't read too much into it?
>>Roman: Yeah.
>>Nick: I mean, they're still pretty core.
I mean trying to put up shortcuts you know,
contact and so on.
That's still a pretty core ability.
>>Roman: Yeah, they're' incredibly useful.
[pause]
>>Nick: So if we ran out of questions, we
could always talk about last night updates
to the design guide chips.
So has anyone seen that thing?
>>Roman: You should talk about it.
>>Rich: Mm-hmm.
>>Roman: Tell us.
>>Rich: I haven't seen it.
>>Alex: [inaudible]
>>Roman: Tell us, tell us.
Go.
>>Nick: Uh, well the thing I thought was really
interesting is if you have the action bar
pattern and the design guide.
There's a little bit of talk about their sliding
drawer navigation pattern which is gaining
some traction as used in the Google plus app.
Or the YouTube app.
And many apps like that.
Like Facebook and Spotify.
So it's nice to see that starting to get formalized
into a pattern for this.
It's a start.
Let's call it that.
>>Roman: Now the kind of the reference and
implementation that you should look at, not
the implementation, sorry.
The reference app you should look at is the
YouTube app.
I believe that that's the screenshot that
we show in the design guideline.
The Google plus app, there's things a little
differently.
So I recommend looking at YouTube.
>>Nick: [unintelligible] widgets, confirming
and acknowledging help and accessibility.
So.
>>Roman: And help includes tutorials.
So like, when to show a tutorial, when not
to show a tutorial.
Hint, you shouldn't really have to show a
tutorial.
Yeah.
>>Nick: Yeah, it's generally better I think,
the goal is UI is so intuitive that you don't
need to have labels and tutorials and so on.
But you know it's almost better to have a
one-time tutorial, like, for say people, with
you've got a lot of complex behavior.
Rather than a lot of the labels in your UI
the whole time.
>>Rich: Any other changes you saw in that?
In the design guideline?
>>Nick: I've not had a chance to look at it.
[laughter]
>>Rich: You've been busy today.
You can check 'em out tonight.
>>Roman: There are a couple updates overall.
I mean, it's also we added for example, a
lot of the graphics there.
Have like the Xoom.
The Galaxy Nexus.
We added the Nexus 7 in there for good measure.
>>Rich: OK.
>>Nick: Into what?
The device generator or what?
>>Roman: Uh, no.
Not the generator.
That's been there.
But, some of the just basic hi-level graphics.
So, if you're showing the page to say, product
managers, they may be like "Oh, what's that?
Is that a seven inch tablet?"
And you can be like "Yeah, we should plan
for seven inch tablets."
>>Nick: [unintelligible]
[pause]
>>Roman: What else we got?
>>Rich: We've got a new visitor in the hangout.
Hey Joe.
Thanks for coming in.
Oh, you're a bit quiet.
I'm not sure if your microphone's muted.
[pause]
>>Roman: Can't hear you.
>>Rich: He's typing.
"My audio isn't working."
You can't hear us either?
No.
OK.
Well you can type the question in the—
>>Nick: [unintelligible]
>>Rich: You can type the question in the chat
window if you have one.
And we can answer it.
And read it out for you.
[pause]
>>Roman: In the mean time, is that another
question in the moderator?
Yes.
>>Rich: Mm-hmm.
>>Sparky: Have we considered?
Yes, we have considered it.
It's been discussed over and over again.
>>Nick: Can you read the question?
>>Sparky: OK.
Have we considered implementing a system which
would allow the user to select if they wish
to allow an individual app to write secure
settings, e.g.: enable GPS?
To enable it's developers to make an app with
better UX.
Yes, it's been discussed at length many many
times.
The problem is just that there is always a
tradeoff between flexibility and tractability.
You know, you give too many affordances and
all of a sudden you have chaos.
Basically can't control the experience in
any way.
So we, I mean, you can correct me if I'm wrong.
But I believe that a lot of these design choices
in the system were an attempt to find the
right balance between giving the user enough
control without overwhelming them with choices.
And requiring the user to spend all their
time making nitpicky minute decisions about
the administration of their device.
That's, for, a classic example is, that's
why you, when you install an app, you either
approve or disapprove all of the permissions
all at once.
When you decide to install or uninstall the
app.
And then you don't have to revisit that decision
again.
>>Roman: yeah, and remember that, that's just
spot on.
Remember that Android users aren't by default,
or aren't in general techies.
So a lot of the features that you think are
"Oh my God, these are must have features.
How do you not have them?"
A lot of those features would be just downright
confusing to the average end user.
So you're absolutely right, there's always
a tradeoff between making something that kind
of intimidates and alienates users, and giving
them enough control.
So.
>>Nick: Alright.
There's a question coming in on the G plus
thread.
Reuben.
Oh.
>>Roman: Should we read Joe's.
>>Rich: Oh, no he's not—
>>Nick: He's not connected.
>>Roman: Oh, sorry.
>>Rich: Can we have a better guide to contacting
him?
>>Matt: I see.
So you're talking about the
>>Sparky: sync provider.
>>Matt: Yeah.
Where essentially you pump in all the information
and the Android system will aggregate them
into the contacts that you have as well as
any kind of social media contacts that you've
got.
All those things.
Is that right?
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Nick: Yeah, there's a great series of blog
posts out there which I often refer to myself.
If you search for um, yeah, see nice.
Sam Steele.
The developer for Google Plus [unintelligible].
He did a serious of blog posts which are excellent.
Is there something that series of blog posts
isn't covering?
Or would just like to see that level of detail
in the official docs?
>>Roman: Also there's a sample sync adapter
which does all of that.
It does contact, syncing.
It does social stream APIs as in Ice Cream
Sandwich.
Sync adapter, authenticator, it does pretty
much all of that.
>>Nick: Yeah.
[pause]
>>Rich: Ah, [unintelligible].
Looks like we [unintelligible]
>>Nick: [unintelligible]
[laughter]
>>Rich: Awesome.
>>Nick: OK, so getting back to this question
asked on the phone.
So Reuben asks "I know that W3C specs the
devices API still unplugs.
But I wonder if there ought to be any support
in Android two point two and two point three
devices for those specs being fleshed out."
So the device API if there is not [unintelligible]
is a browser.
Like APIs that are allowing access like the
camera and images and so on.
Like there's an input site.
So my initial reaction is probably, no.
Because that would require an update to the
browser.
And the browser as you know it's part of the
system image of the device.
So we're not able to update that outside of
a firmware update.
So I would be very surprised to see that happen.
Unfortunately.
Maybe other browsers.
Like, so I know Chrome is ICS onwards.
But maybe some other browsers might be able
to offer support there.
But now with this soft Android browser or
the web view, I don't think.
>>Rich: Uh.
Hm.
[pause]
Well.
>>Nick: New attendees there.
>>Rich: People flooding in now.
Oren.
And Johannes.
And Yosi, I can't find the trace.
OK.
Maybe the next Office Hours.
We will be back next Wednesday at two pm.
>>Nick: Yeah, Yosi.
That sounds like the kind of thing you should
probably place into stack overflow.
Post, and then link to it in our Moderator.
That sounds like the right way to attack this.
>>Rich: Ooooh.
Can Johannes ask a question regarding native
audio?
Anybody wanna hear?
>>Sparky: You can try.
[laughter]
>>Rich: Native audio guy.
>>Roman: You might be better off looking to
the [unintelligible].
>>Rich: Lots of faces.
>>Johannes: OK.
Hi guys.
>>Rich: Hi.
You're gonna ask it anyway.
[laughs]
>>Johannes: So this is a question I had for
a long time now.
So basically your documentation says that
you support the open SL audio library for
3D audio and some stuff around that.
But if I implement listener, sound listener
and a sound source, inside of open SL, and
I try to assign a 3D space to that, I get
this ominous "error 12" which says "This feature
is not supported" which is weird.
Because your documentation says you support
3D audio.
But if you try to implement it, it's not working.
>>Rich: Mm.
That is the kind of question I would refer
to the expertise of stack overflow on—
>>Nick: I would say, if you can stay up for
the US Office Hours tonight, some guys from
the media team who would have written our
implementation are going to be joining our
US colleagues.
So if you can come back in 8 hours time.
>>Rich: [laughs]
>>Nick: It's probably the best place to get
an answer for that question.
>>Johannes: When is that exactly?
>>Nick: It's two p.m. Pacific time.
>>Rich: You can see it if you go to—
>>Nick: So eight hours from now.
>>Rich: Uh, better to stalk google.com/live.
>>Johannes: OK.
Thank you.
>>Nick: Yeah, well, sorry to [unintelligible]
>>Rich: Sorry [unintelligible].
>>Johannes: Problem.
Stack Overflow can't help either.
>>Rich: No, I can see it in the Google groups.
They have the same thing.
"I tried to use [inaudible] LES.
I get unsupported error 12."
Mick says, "It depends on which profile flags
the model it was compiled with."
So the fact that you get an unsupported error
probably means they didn't include the audio
effect from that device.
Interesting.
So yeah.
Best to just ask the team this evening.
>>Johannes: OK.
Thank you.
>>Rich: Or ask it in the Moderator.
You can go through the developers.com link
to get to Moderator.
And you can just type into there.
And then you can watch the video back tomorrow,
hope they'll answer it.
Al Sutton.
Where did he come from.
[laughter]
>>Matt: There he is.
>>Rich: Sneaky.
>>Al: I'm sneaky when you're not looking,
Rich.
[laughter]
>>Rich: So, Al has just posted the link in
the chat window on the left there to the show
for tonight's—
>>Nick: He's the Hangout ninja.
>>Rich: Hangout Ninja Al Sutton has joined
in.
[laughter]
I know.
Yeah.
We're having the low-level media team which
will help to figure that out.
>>Nick: You're back home Al.
I thought you were in London this morning.
>>Al: I got back about half an hour ago.
>>Nick: Ah.
>>Al: So I've been fighting Chrome which doesn't
do Hangouts on air, so took me a bit to get
in.
>>Rich: Oh.
Interesting.
OK.
>>Al: I've got a question for you guys if
you want one.
>>Rich: Yeah.
Feel free to ask.
>>Al: I've been working on an application
that basically turns the user's phone into
a game pad.
So you can connect to another device using
Bluetooth, and you can play on your tablet
and use your phone as a controller.
What's the best way to handle user defined
layouts.
Is it to use a canvas view or should I be
looking at using one of the layout managers?
And restricting users positions for buttons
and things like that to what the layout manager
can handle.
>>Rich: So you wanna allow users to specify
where all the buttons are on the tablet screen?
>>Al: Absolutely.
Yep.
So if I wanna have the control pad thumb pad
on the left or the right, they can move it
over.
Things like that.
>>Alex: Speaking of a few apps that have user
defined layouts, I definitely prefer the canvas
approach.
Because what you end up with when you try
to get things into the layout manager is invariably
a grid that you can draw buttons on.
And it's just very limiting.
So I've actually played around with a few
remote control apps.
Where you control your TV.
When you move buttons around.
But the grid isn't very conducive.
Especially if you're making a game pad.
And you want to use familiar patterns.
Like maybe the little diamond and ADXY buttons
on the side of the d-pad.
And these things don't work if you line them
up in a grid.
Or if they do they're spaced really far apart
and it would be really awkward.
So speaking as a user, I would like your app
better if it used canvas.
>>Roman: If you wanted to do a drag and drop
with a non-canvas.
Let's say you did something similar look in
Absolute Layout.
Like a custom layout that was effectively
an absolute layout, using things like x and
y coordinates.
As you're dragging to show real time updates,
some of these.
You'd have to basically do a layout pass.
Every single drag.
Right.
You'd have to read through your layout.
Even if it's just within that view.
Just within that view group.
It may be pretty slow, I guess.
So I think just the canvass is going to give
you more flexibility and less pain all together.
>>Nick: it's like, well I find some of the
game which have like a d-pad input, the ones
I like the most are the ones which don't force
you to a particular position.
But they let you put your foot, your finger
down.
It just centers on wherever you place your
finger.
So I think the mad finger games like Shadow
Gun and Dead Trigger, right.
And so if you've got to call it if you offer
something like that.
So you know, you don't have a physical anchor
point to locate with your finger.
Just letting it touchdown where you move relatively
from that would be kind of cool.
But just my—
>>Al: I was thinking along those lines.
One of those things that I've gotta take into
account is the application's already got a
window that's a feedback window from the game
itself.
So if you're playing, say for example, a games
console connected to a TV that runs Android,
the game itself can feed back information
to be displayed on the controller pad.
So I'm trying to make sure that they can be
positioned where that information can still
be seen.
So there might be some limitations.
But the idea of centering it on where you
push could be quite cool.
thanks Nick.
>>Nick: Alright.
>>Rich: Good question.
Cheers Al.
A number of things popped into the Moderator
whilst we've been talking.
>>Roman: "How should a sync provider behave
that syncs files or anything?
Not accessible using a content resolver."
I'm not sure I understand the question.
>>Alex: But you delivered it so well.
>>Rich: One [unintelligible] length.
>>Matt: In an Anglo-Saxon [unintelligible]
>>Sparky: [laughs]
>>Rich: How should a sync provider behave?
>>Johannes: I had another question.
If you need one.
Maybe?
>>Rich: OK, we'll think about that one whilst
Johannes asks the next question.
Go ahead.
>>Johannes: OK so is it possible to override
the GSM stack for implementing your own phone
application?
Just not only a dialer but a complete phone?
Or sending for example GSM codes without getting
dialog box as a result?
>>Roman: The only access to the telephony
or-- you don't have any access really to the
telephony or the radio.
Well you can use sieve, right?
I mean if you're—
>>Rich: Well, he wants to do that slash code
thing.
>>Alex: So he's actually asking about the
GSMs?
If you write your own Android ROM.
>>Rich: ROM.
Yeah.
>>Al: Yeah.
>>Rich: Sorry.
That's like doing your own custom ROM.
>>Johannes: OK.
>>Rich: The ASP ROMs.
That's gonna be a tricky thing.
That's insecure.
>>Roman: How should a sync provider behave?
I'm still trying to parse this question.
How should a sync provider behave that syncs
files or anything not accessible.
So maybe—
>>Alex: Maybe it syncs anything not accessible
in content resolver.
>>Roman: Maybe it's trying to block the content
provider.
Or sync provider from being accessible by
other apps?
>>Matt: Yeah.
>>Roman: uh.
>>Nick: I think you can do anything, 'cause
like—
>>Roman: 'cause export equals false.
Will that even work?
So basically the sync provider is a service,
right?
It's a—
>>Al: I think what he's trying to ask is,
if you've got a sync provider that's trying
to synchronize something for your application
that you can't feed to it via a content provider,
is there a recommended way of doing it?
'Cause he's talking about files.
But I know there's a method in content provider
of reading files.
Is there one to write files as well?
>>Roman: I have no clue.
>>Nick: Yeah, I think.
>>Roman: So first of all, we're not talking
about sync adapters.
We're talking about sync providers?
>>Al: I think he's talking about sync adapters.
But I've not been able to come up with classes.
>>Roman: Yeah, I don't know what a sync provider
is.
>>Nick: Because it performs sync method, right?
Where you can do anything.
>>Roman: So sync adapters are, the only correlation,
the only way in which sync adapters interact
with content providers is via the authority.
Its' just a link right.
Sync adapters don't inherently have to even
use a provider at all.
Like, there's no API that's specific to sync
adapters.
>>Nick: That's what I'm thinking.
Yeah.
So I think we should move on unless Markus
can give us a little bit more context.
>>Rich: Yeah.
Not able to answer the question.
Oh.
Matthias.
Hello.
Thanks for joining us today.
He says "Any news on this issue?"
Oh that.
Code.com.
"I'm getting bad reviews thanks to this issue.
" Let's click on it.
It says "I have certain Android install locations
that internal only in my paid app.
The APK itself installs to data apps.
Instead, however, Google play installs the
app to mount ASEC this causes a major problem
for my app, because it's primarily an Android
service.
As the service is generated before ASEC is
mounted, it can't find my service and widget.
All associated accounts, in Google data.
>>Nick: it's a problem with codes and API.
And it shifts internally.
It just doesn't shift—
>>Rich: OK.
Where did the window go.
>>Nick: I guess, unfortunately this falls
under 'can't talk release dates' cause we
don't know them and they'll probably change.
>>Rich: But the news on the issue is we do
know about it.
We know what it's caused by, and its' being
worked on.
Sorry about that.
[laughter]
>>Nick: Sorry we can't share anymore.
[pause]
>>Rich: No.
Generally they won't be.
That's fine.
But, the Play Store, updates separate to Android.
And the Android families.
So they can push updates out at any time they
want.
So as soon as they fix it I'm sure they'll
push that out.
Once it's tested and it'll all just start
working without you having to make changes
to your app.
>>Nick: I'm not sure about that.
I think it might [chiv] up the install process.
>>Roman: Baggage manager?
>>Nick: Baggage manager actually installs
the same incorrect information on it.
But um--
>> Roman: The other good news is that in general,
if you look at Ice Cream Sandwich.
If you look at Gingerbread.
I mean the very first version that gets released
doesn't stick around for too long.
So, Ice Cream Sandwich four point oh, point
one, four point oh, point two.
They're not really sticking around so much.
Four point oh point three, four point oh point
four, they're getting a lot of traction.
This is not an absolute statement by any means.
But just historically the very first version
of a major dessert name release hasn't really
stuck around for too long.
Its immediate successor is really—
>>Rich: This is true.
>>Nick: [unintelligible]
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Nick: The ad monitor [unintelligible].
>>Rich: Is there an update to an IO developers
reply to comment?
No there's no update on that either, sorry
Joe.
[laughter]
>>Al: It is rolling out to more developers
though.
I've talked to a few who've received it in
the last week.
So it looks like it's more widely available.
>>Rich: OK.
>>Nick: Yeah, I think the team's beta testing
it.
So yeah.
>>Roman: "Beeta".
You Brits and beta.
>>Rich: What are you, "bay-ta" testing it?
>>Roman: "Bay-ta."
>>Rich: "Bay-ta" testing.
[laughter]
>>Al: Don't forget to "bay-ta" wi' your data.
That's how I always remember.
>>Alex: You really watch the A beta.
>>Rich: "Bay-ta!"
Um.
NPerch is asking in the Moderator "Is there
an API for pulling all the application data
out of the Play Store?"
Nope.
[laughter]
"What's the best way to have a—" This is
from Nooki of [unintelligible].
"what's the best way to have a horizontal
scrolling list or grid on Android?
Since both list view and grid view are only
vertical?"
>>Roman: Write your own.
>>Rich: Write your own.
Use a view pager that's actually a view pager.
Works quite well for this, depending on how
big you're gonna have.
>>Matt: What about the gallery?
>>Rich: Gallery is now deprecated.
>>Matt: Is it?
Cool.
>>Roman: Is it officially deprecated?
>>Sparky: Are we officially dedicated?
>>Roman: [unintelligible]
>>Nick: It's like that.
[laughter]
>>Alex: Look at that excitement.
>>Roman: Gallery, yeah, gallery can work in
some cases.
But the physics, the touch physics are all
screwed up.
>>Rich: Uh.
>>Alex: Could you just put a linear kind of
scroll in?
>>Matt: It could work.
>>Roman: Yeah.
You could use your horizontal scroll.
The good thing about list view and [unintelligible]
view is that [unintelligible].
>>Nick: Just a sec.
Right there.
And then down, down, down, down, and then—
>>Roman: [unintelligible] you have like a
10,000 item, for the scroll view.
Is it deprecated?
>>Rich: This class is deprecated.
>>Roman: Yes!
>>Rich: [unintelligible]
>>Matt: [inaudible]
>>Rich: Other horizontally scroll widgets
include horizontal scroll, view, and view
pager from the support library.
>>Roman: So if you want like an actual horizontal
list view that does all the [unintelligible]
recycling—
>>Rich: Yeah.
>>Roman: We don't have one.
But there are third party projects.
>>Nick: Yeah, just Google "horizontal list
view."
>>Roman: Yeah, horizontal.
>>Nick: Android.
there's a ton out there.
But I said View Pager gets you on the [unintelligible].
>>Roman: One other interesting thing about
View Pager.
So View Pager also does, it doesn't do the
recycling, but it follows the adapter patterns.
So you can implement the recycling yourself.
Launch is not very complicated.
One thing I'll say is that in the recent versions
of the support library, I think as of R8 or
later.
View Pager, actually Pager Adapter has this
new method called "get page width" which lets
you create pages that are not full width.
So you can create a page that is 25 percent
of the screen width.
And so you'll see four pages at a time.
Or a page that is 50 percent screen width,
so you'll see two at a time.
And the touch physics work well there.
There's no inertial fling or anything like
that.
You guys are—
>>Nick: On pages?
I see, you get full, next door, next door.
>>Roman: Yeah.
Well actually you advance one page at a time
so you've got one, like—
>>Nick: So that you'd get like one to the
left.
>>Roman: Yeah.
So you locate items one and two.
And you go one more and you'd see items two
and three, not three and four.
>>Nick: Could you have full width?
>>Roman: Well, actually, that's a good question.
We'll have to check it out sometime.
>>Alex: So you've got, its View Pager so you
definitely, if it's a 10,000 item list you
can't just do a whoosh.
>>Roman: [unintelligible] Right.
The other thing is, if you're quite fancy
with RUNDLL script a example which is called
carousel view, that's somewhere.
Just search for "carousel example Android"
it'll show you how to do like a music, a Google
music style 3D carousel.
Not so much horizontal as it is three dimensional.
But yeah, I don't know, it's, linked to Google
IO talk.
[tablet music playing]
[laughter]
>>Roman: Last year.
Somewhere last year.
Right.
>>Rich: Right.
Those two versions would be rendered script
carousel.
One of them is actually understandable and
quite boring.
Or the one that's tricky and it's amazing.
'cause the sample code in there, the sample
code for run script has one version that may
be hard to understand.
But the music player one I think is 20,000
lines of run script in one file.
One large file.
>>Roman: It's meant to be like a flexible.
'Cause the [unintelligible] where the higher
level API, you just press the five basic things.
Like.
>>Nick: They'll go to the RS files.
>>Roman: Yeah.
>>Nick: That'd be dragging them.
[laughter]
>> Roman: Unless you want your eyes [unintelligible]
>>Rich: That's OK.
[laughter]
>>Matt: [unintelligible] your eyes?
>>Nick: Also, it's not worth learning [unintelligible]
>>Roman: Yeah.
>>Rich: Also—
[laughter]
>>Nick: There was some chat going on on sidebar
about Google wire framing tools.
Which I know is one of Roman's favorite topics.
So I'd say, pencil and paper.
Or fluid drawing.
And the [unintelligible]
>>Roman: We have official stencils.
For OmniGraffle.
That would be FireWorks.
FireWorks is very good.
If you wanna do interactive wire frames, like
where you can click on a button and actually
flip to the page that the button would be
to the left.
>>Nick: [unintelligible] 'cause FireWorks
is so flaky.
>>Roman: Yeah.
[laughter]
>>Roman: Also there's phototrap stencil, so
I mean, outside of the official stencils kit,
there are FireWorks, phototrap, OmniGraffle.
If you were to use any other too.
Pencil for Firefox, you mentioned.
They just added a Android four point oh stencil
kit built in.
or just available for download.
And Fluid UI also comes with that.
With and Android four point oh.
So it's, yeah.
>>Rich: So.
Uh.
Questions flying in now.
We've got eight minutes left so I'm not sure
we're going to get through them all.
But Yosi, who is still working on his dialog,
his [unintelligible] or whatever, has asked,
is there a way of showing progress on a dialog?
[unintelligible] no.
[unintelligible]
>>Roman: Oh, like as a window feature?
>>Yosi: Yeah, the same was in the window feature,
just showing the web page loading progress
on the top of the dialog, the title or something
like.
That.
>>Roman: You have to look at it yourself.
So the window feature is specific to [inaudible]
>>Roman: Like for example, dialogs can't even
have action bars at all.
That's partly because of the, for the same
reason.
So you'd have to just have a progress bar
or something.
>>Yosi: So the best way to implement it is
to have a progress bar above the web view
and show the progress as you go along loading
the URL?
>>Roman: Yeah.
Um, in general, I mean, you're saying, web
view inside of a dialog.
And that's very kind of starting to scare
me.
[laughter]
>>Yosi: It's from the application web view.
If you can see it.
I don't know.
I have the permissions done.
Just showing the user, uh, I don't know if
you can see it or something.
[laughter]
>>Roman: So in general, don't be afraid of
full screen windows.
I mean, users don't-- users have awful memory
but not that awful.
Like, they're—
[laughter]
>>Yosi: Yeah, I have a full window of the,
um, showing the progress bar and everything.
But I think it's more flowing to the user
and more comprehensive to show when using
two panes, then clicking on the left pane
and showing the dialog.
And then after selecting in dialog, or making
it the authentication, then the right pane
shows the content you want to go and fetch
from for the user.
>>Roman: OK.
>>Yosi: I think it's a better UI flow for
the user.
>>Roman: OK.
Yeah, so in that case you are probably just
going to have to make your own progress bar.
>>Nick: Yeah, as Joe says in his the sidebar,
I would try linear, linear, linear layout
with the progress bar above the work you're
doing.
So.
>>Roman: One thing is that the progress bar
has built in padding.
So there will be actually on ICS and even
Anycom, the tail end, or I guess the head
of the progress bar is actually a globe.
So it has some built in padding to account
for that.
So if you use a linear layout then your web
view will appear below the globe.
>>Nick: Maybe do a frame layout for it.
>>Roman: Yeah.
You may wanna do a frame layout and have the
progress bar neatly, like the middle of the
progress bar aligned with the top edge of
the web view.
That's what Chrome and the built in browser
do.
>>Yosi: OK.
Thanks.
>>Rich: I'm searching for [VoIP] now.
Jake knew what it was.
It's a client for Android, right?
>>Roman: Oh yeah.
>>Rich: Are you on the VoIP team there, Joe?
Oh, you can't talk, can you, sorry.
You'll have to do by hand signals.
>>Nick: You can do thumbs up, thumbs down,
mime, [inaudible]
>>Rich: Oh.
Nine [unintelligible]
>>Roman: Yeah, it's, it's, good [inaudible]
>>Rich: [inaudible]
>>Male #1: Um.
I've got a quick—
>>Rich: [growls]
>>Male #1: Android question that I want to
ask.
Um.
Where can I find Google Wallet?
I tried to find it.
>>Rich: In America.
[laughter]
>>Roman: [unintelligible]
>>Rich: Now, we don't have Google Wallet.
Sorry.
>>Roman: [inaudible]
[laughter]
>>Alex: Why not?
>>Rich: [unintelligible]
>>Nick: Then on top of that, the carriers
and—
>>Male #1: I'm asking because it's actually
started working in Israel.
Some shops, some people actually manage to
pay with Google Wallet.
Which is quite funny.
[laughter]
>>Al: It's all based on MasterCard's PayPass
which is a global standard.
So you can do it in the UK as well in McDonalds
and places like that.
>>Male #1: Yeah, so.
>>Al: What do you need to do?
>>Nick: [inaudible] and that's where you find
it.
>>Al: If you can get hold of a Galaxy Nexus
or a device for which the stock firmware is
produced, you can put the US firmware from
the Google developer's site on it.
Put a US SIM in the phone and you'll get full
working Google Wallet functionality.
If it doesn't have a US SIM in, it won't work.
>>Male #1: [laughs] Yeah.
>>Al: --picked up from my trip to the States.
>>Yosi: Yeah.
We tried it a few times on Google IO and found
out that you need to—
>>Nick: Yeah, I think [unintelligible] buying
his Gregg's Pasties with his Nexus 7.
[laughter]
>>Male #1: But I tried it from the market
website.
Uh, you know the Play website.
Full website on the PC and I even faked my
IP so I can access it the US store and I didn't
find it there.
So I can only find it from a Galaxy Nexus?
In—
>>Nick: You want us to teach you how to hack
the Play Store so that—
>>Male #1: No.
I'm not that [inaudible]
[laughter]
>> Male #1: No, I said I didn't even find
it on there.
>>Rich: And that's the end of today's broadcast.
[laughter]
>>Roman: But IP isn't, I don't think IP is
the only signal we use to determine what the
[inaudible]
>>Rich: Yes, [unintelligible] different ones
out so he can just break the [inaudible]
>>Johannes: But isn't Wallet a system application?
So that is maybe the reason why it's not available
in the Play Store.
>>Al: It's available by the Play Store but
it's triggered off of the SIM inside the device.
So unless you've got a US carrier SIM in the
device, your chances of installing or being
useable would actually be none.
>>Yosi: Yeah, but if you have a Nexus 7 tablet,
then you don't have a SIM.
So based on the location, the Play Store app
should work.
>>Nick: Yeah, I was going to say, this isn't
an Android developer question.
>>Rich: Yeah.
Let's not—
[laughter]
>>Rich: I wonder if there's anything else.
>>Roman: Two minutes!
>>Rich: Two minutes.
Is anything, anyone in the Hangout have anything
they really wanna say in the last two minutes?
'cause thank you very much for all joining
us.
>>Yosi: First of all, thank you.
And, one last question.
How can I get my app featured.
What is the best—
[laughter]
>>Rich: Yes.
We all have to drink now.
If anyone asks that in a Hangout, we all have
to drink.
[laughter]
>>Rich: Someone asks that every single week.
>>Yosi: Yeah.
I know.
>>Al: Just so you can drink the double, how
do I get my Google Plus page verified?
[laughter]
>>Nick: Uh, if you think you have a great
app, maybe submit it to the Friday Review.
And—
>>Roman: The Friday App Clinic.
>>Nick: Clinic.
My bad.
Have to rewire my brain.
>>Rich: Drink.
[chuckles]
>>Nick: So yeah, that's a good way to get
it in front of people.
Like always.
Just like, how are you promoting it at the
moment?
>>Yosi: Basically we're doing some campaigns
on different websites and different stores.
Like on Samsung store and the Amazon.
And so on and so on.
With affiliates.
And we want to see how to get our app featured
in the Play Store.
'cause that's the best way to get our app
be more visible.
'cause we already have like six and a half
million downloads already.
>>Nick: Wow.
>>Yosi: Yeah.
And—
>>Nick: What's the app?
>>Alex: What' s the app called?
>>Yosi: OoVoo.
>>Rich: What?
OoVoo?
Are you OoVoo?
>>Sparky: Is it the video player, uh, video
conferencing?
>>Yosi: Yeah.
>>Rich: Double-O, V, double-O?
>>Yosi: Social video chat.
>>Rich: Sorry.
>>Roman: Yeah.
I know that.
>>Yosi: That's the one.
>>Al: Isn't' there a checklist of things people
should do to help it get featured?
>>Sparky: Well we do know what not to not
do to not get not featured.
Because that was at Google IO.
[laughter]
>>Roman: There's a blog post by Natasha [ ] that
talks about your image guidelines.
Like your play listing guidelines.
Like your featured graphic.
Your titles.
Your descriptions.
There are some things that are just very simple,
things to make sure you have.
>>Alex: We don't actually offer a definitive
list of "do x, y, and z and you will get featured."
Uh, but we provide a wealth of information
on things that will get you not featured.
And.
>>Nick: Such as using an iPad layout.
[laughter]
>>Alex: Right.
>>Yosi: [clears throat loudly]
[group laughs and comments]
>>Alex: Also you need to clear before featuring
you.
That's a consideration.
So Dan Galpin and Ian Ni-Lewis gave a talk
at IO that was—
>>Nick: Aimed at games.
I think it was.
"Ten things every game developer should know."
Right?
>>Alex: Right.
But a good chunk of that was things that will
get you not featured on Google Play.
Also, like you said, Natasha [ ] post on,
what was it you said?
On like the resources that you use?
And like looking good in Google Play?
>>Sparky: Yeah.
Like dimensions for your promotional graphics.
>>Nick: It was just talking about pitching
graphics.
>>Alex: One mistake a lot of people do is
they upload smaller application graphics when
they're told they have to upload a larger
banner-size one.
So they just blow up the first one.
It's this huge blurry mess that we would never
put on the front page of Google Play.
>>Nick: No, what's worse is they say "Hey,
it's 1024 pixels wide by 500 high."
>>Roman: Just take the screws out of our IDE.
>>Nick: Well they squish like tons of text
in there and then when we wanna feature the
application 'cause that's gonna get like shrunk
down from this big on the website to this
big on the phone.
Like, it's just illegible.
So.
>>Rich: Things like that.
But I would say, look at your screenshots.
That a little bit of application of our design
guidelines would certainly help any potential
featuring.
>>Roman: Yeah.
Definitely.
>>Yosi: Yeah, I'm', we're doing a redesign
for all the app 'cause the main issue was,
before I got to Google was—
>>Rich: yeah, maybe when that's ready.
>>Yosi: Most of the features from the iPhone,
in order to do a cross-platform remote.
You know when you want to do a fluid cross
platform from UI.
And when I came to Google, we started working
on the design guidelines and all that.
And that's what we're doing right now.
We're implementing a new version to be download,
to be published in the market in the next
few weeks.
And that will be better design.
And hopefully the next version will be even
better.
>>Nick: So that sounds great.
So once you have this new version kind of
launched, maybe you could time a big push
around that.
So if you try and pick up some play in the
media, maybe get some adverting around the
application.
And then submit it to the Friday Clinic as
well and we can take a look at it.
So if you try and time all the push around
your relaunch that could be a good time.
>>Yosi: OK.
Thank you.
>>Rich: Alright.
Well we've gone overtime.
But thank you all very much for joining in
today.
Those of you on YouTube as well who have been
watching the stream.
Thanks for joining this massive crowd with
us.
All six of us today.
Here in London.
And we'll see you all again same time next
week.
Cheers.
[all say "Bye" and "Cheers"]